on Monday February 17th 2003 the Antwerp
diamond police walked into a vault that
was two floors underground the diamond
district and discovered that thieves had
broken into a vault that had ten layers
of security and they had systematically
disabled each one and made off with an
estimated hundred million euros worth of
diamonds
to me what's so amazing about this story
is that these thieves were the cream of
the crop they were from Italy they were
extremely accomplished they were at the
top of their game and yet as they drove
out of town they pulled off the road and
threw a bag of garbage out the window
into a forested area beside the freeway
they didn't burn it
it was just scattered in the underbrush
and they left and it just so happened
that this little piece of forest was
owned by a retired grocer who had made
it his life work and retirement to try
to prevent littering and improve nature
and for him the garbage was just a huge
insult everything he was trying to do
with his retirement and so he would
regularly call the cops when he would
find garbage on his land and say you
know oh there's there's some beer
bottles or there's this or there's that
in the police we're like yeah yes thank
you Mr Bond calm but this time this
Monday morning mr. van Kampf found this
garbage and it was unusual garbage it
wasn't you know the typical beer bottles
and wine bottles so those things were
there but there were also diamonds in
the mud and within an hour the area was
swarmed with cops the alleged mastermind
of the operation was a man named
leonardo notarbartolo who his specialty
was charmed leonardo notarbartolo says
he's always been a thief he was born to
be a thief he made his first robbery he
was 6 years old I started following the
story six years ago in 2003 I was in
Antwerp at the time reporting another
story about diamonds and it was while I
was there that I heard about this heist
I was there maybe two or three months
after it had occurred and I thought wow
that's an amazing story and I would love
to know what really happened and so I
got in touch with notarbartolo first
with his lawyer in Belgium and then I
also started sending in letters in
prison
and one day I received a phone call at
home here in California and it was
leonardo notarbartolo calling me after
six years there were four people who
were arrested charged and convicted with
the crime according notarbartolo there
were five people he refuses to say who
these people were but he uses their
nicknames there was the man he refers to
as the genius a guy who could disable
any surveillance system any kind of
alarm this guy was your man there was a
man named the monster who was
monstrously talented he was basically an
all-around Olympian of Thieves
the third guy was a man named the king
of keys kind of self-explanatory and the
fourth man on the team
not counting the DeBartolo was known as
speedy speedy was an old friend of
notarbartolo they've grown up together
and the others on the team didn't want
him he started to have anxiety problems
but no to bartylla thought that this was
the job of a lifetime and if they were
gonna make the biggest score of their
life he couldn't really say to his old
oldest and closest friend no you're not
in on this unfortunately it was speedy
who had a panic attack as they were
driving out of Antwerp after the heist
and it was his insistence that they pull
off the road and immediately get rid of
the garbage that explains why the
garbage ended up on Van coms land it was
never note about Tula's intention to do
that it was a mistake it was a reaction
to his friends meltdown notarbartolo
always planned to drive the garbage to
France and burn it in an abandoned
warehouse if he had done that it's
possible the heist would never have been
solved